think about the total amount of  attention that exists on the planet  eyeballs and ear balls are going  everywhere at all times platforms are  there to catch them and create more  value than what they're currently  consuming when you were bored having a  radio interrupted silence was something  interesting but then when they did  multimedia through television which is  sound and video that was more  interesting than just radio unless  you're occupied and you can only do one  because you need your other attention  source forms will always continue to  evolve but the nice thing is they will  always only hit the three senses that we  have that we can communicate through